حسنًا ، هذا هو المكان الذي قال فيه الرئيس الأوكراني
فلاديمير لنسكي أن بعض
أعنف المعارك كانت بالأمس جسرًا رئيسيًا
على مشارف ابنها ،
وهو الطريق المؤدي إلى
أوكرانيا الرئيسية من شبه جزيرة
القرم التي تسيطر عليها روسيا في عام 2014. ويمكنك أن ترى
حولي  كان هناك
دمار كبير هنا على مدار الـ 48 ساعة الماضية ، من
الواضح أن المبنى قد تعرض لضربة مباشرة على
الأرجح من بعض الغارات الجوية
التي سمعناها ، ومن
العدل أن نقول إن هذه المدينة مرعوبة
من إطفاء أضواءها الليلة الماضية ، رأينا
الفنادق تغرق نفسها  في الظلام ،
يسأل الأطفال عما يحدث
من طائرات تحلق على ارتفاع منخفض قادمة
ودوي الضربات الجوية البعيدة
ونيران الأسلحة الصغيرة المتقطعة ، كما قيل لي عن
الجثث التي تم إحضارها من هنا ،
رأينا رجلان للأسف غادروا
في منتصف الطريق.  هناك
ولكن الضرر كبير
هنا ونستمر في
السير نحو محطة البنزين هذه ، حيث
ترى نوعًا من
المعالم المحلية الغريبة التي  انتهى الأمر
بكونه محور القتال ومن
الواضح أن الجيش الأوكراني اتخذ موقفًا
مهمًا
هنا
وتسبب في الكثير من الأضرار التي لحقت
بمركباتهم التي ربما تكون عسكرية وكذلك
يبدو أن الأمور قد توقفت وحيث
كانت المواقع الأخيرة للقوات الأوكرانية
أه  إنهم بعيدون قليلاً
عن هنا ، لا نعطي تفاصيل أه
عندما نكون من حولهم ولكن من الواضح
أنه كانت هناك
آثار لقذائف قريبة
أعتقد أنها جزء من قميص عسكري للرجال
ولا تزال بعض قذائف المدفعية
ملقاة على  الجانب هنا غير مستخدم من
محطة الوقود هذه ، يبدو أنه
قد تعرض لضربة كبيرة حيث تم قلب الشاحنة
،
وأحد الأشياء التي نضعها في الاعتبار هو
خزان الغاز الذي يبدو أنه يحترق ببطء
في هذا الاتجاه ،
ما هو غير عادي أن نراه هنا هو مدى
سرعة المدنيين  تعود الحياة إلى هذه
المنطقة اليأس التي لا
يعتقد الناس أنها آمنة ، فهم
يحاولون تجاوزها لرؤية الأشخاص الذين يهتمون
لأمرهم يفعلون ما يحتاجون إلى القيام به كل يوم
ولكن على النقيض  مع ذلك والنوع المطلق
من القوة النارية التي نراها مستخدمة
هنا ، يجب أن يكون هذا بالتأكيد
نوعًا من الغارة الجوية ، أعني أن التأثير
يبدو أنه قد يكون جاء من هذا
الجانب الأوكراني
ولكن هذه الدبابات معطلة
وكل من حولنا  بالضبط ما
تعنيه حكومة أوكرانيا من خلال اشتداد
القتال هنا